so if you like eSports you probably hate
cheaters it's just that simple
so when riot unveiled valor n't they did
so with the promise of stopping hackers
right in their tracks but it comes at a
cost an intrusive piece of software
called Vanguard that runs on your
computer constantly so what's the deal
with this thing is it a breach of
privacy or is this what it takes to
actually catch the cheaters let me give
you all the answers
[Music]
Keith what are you doing I'm just trying
to order some food quickly we're in the
middle of a shoot dad relax it's 5
o'clock that means I can use my grub up
daily perk and I can get some value when
I order this pizza are you really doing
this right now
yeah from 5 p.m. to 9 p.m. I can use
grubs daily perk to get $10 off when I
spend $30 at select restaurants then I
can support my favorite places during
covin 19 all right fine we're swapping
in Devon this week fine go deal with him
Devon are you also ordering food I mean
yeah of course dude why wouldn't I it's
safe it's easy there's contact free
delivery so I don't have to go outside
and I get to support my favorite places
so I mean it's 2020 dan come on okay
fine
we're going back to Keith I guess yeah
all right cool I got my order in so
let's go back to the story so Valerie is
I would in closed beta and I think it's
safe to say that so far it's a massive
success the game gives you that crisp
and clean counter-strike esque gun feel
it's dominating on Twitch and to me it
looks like it has a pretty bright future
as far as competitive play and eSports
goes and that's been riots plan all
along from the very beginning the first
announcement they advertise PI server
tick rates optimize performance and high
frames and of course a powerful anti
cheat system that system is called
Vanguard it downloads with Valerie asks
you to restart your computer and then
runs on startup from then on it even
when you're not playing down this thing
is just always chugging along in the
background and for some people that's
pretty unsettling there's been a lot of
backlash about just how intrusive this
program is and whether or not that level
of invasiveness is necessary in an anti
cheat program people all over the
internet have been calling this a breach
of privacy and many are looking at riot
and Tencent the company that owns them
in China who are also very close with
the Chinese government and questioning
their motives but with that in mind
today I'm gonna try to dispel a lot of
misinformation about this subject and to
do that I called in some experts I spoke
with a guy who goes by gamer dog
he runs an organization called the
overwatch Police Department we spoke to
him for a don't at me episode we did a
few weeks ago they infiltrate reading
circles get cheaters band notified
developers about new cheats they're
basically the Batman of getting cheaters
caught being an expert on the subject of
cheating I wanted to get his take on
valor and early on how intrusive this
software actually was and some of the
early reports of cheating in the game
and the first thing he told me was that
he'd actually already caught a wall
hacker basically 48 hours after the
closed beta dropped the engine that the
game is running on is Unreal Engine 4
and there's a source codes for that
there's a lot of things so you can make
cheats really easier on Valiant
because of its engine the anti cheat is
where it says nah you're not you're not
getting in this game it's it just throws
you out basically so you need to find a
way to bypass that anti cheat in order
to get your cheat in there and also you
also have to maintain it undetected and
that is going to be really hard with
this anti cheat with the information it
gathers on cheaters according to gamer
doc if you actually want to catch
cheaters like you're actually serious
about this your software needs to be
intrusive full stuff if your anti cheat
isn't their cheat will be and you're
sunk every modern cheat is running ring
0 because why not why would you not it's
you're just not gonna get detected the
fact is there's so much money in selling
cheats that there will always be another
programmer willing to go the extra mile
to cheat the system and because of that
it's imperative that programs like
Vanguard run on startup and run
constantly because if they don't the
cheats themselves will and then the
problem just continues I promise [ __ ] is
if any company is not being intrusive
with their anti cheat they're not gonna
detect any cheats like that's just
that's just a reality of it like
blizzard
really respects privacy and they're
being really stubborn about it and I can
understand that but sheets are gonna
become more intrusive and more intrusive
it's not going to stop at all remember
like the day after Valerie opened in
closed beta everyone was watching it on
Twitch and we heard about cheaters like
right away well it was actually gamer
dog who helped hedge that there's one
internal cheats that we have found we
gave it to Riot why it has completely
nuke that nuke that sheets can actually
a band a couple of people he told me
like double digit accounts were banned
and this is just right off the hop it's
important to note that this program for
the most part it catches cheaters it
doesn't stop them from cheating in the
first place and just a few days after
launch we've already seen some cheaters
come and once this thing goes live we
know that there's gonna be more so
that's why this kind of intrusive
software is so important ok so now let's
get into how Vanguard actually works and
do a little bit of myth fuss
let me try to break down the technical
side of this based on my interviews
Vanguard uses what's called a kernel
driver which boots up on your computer
before your user mode starts to work
kernel drivers start up in the kernel
layer of your computer and I mean for
you and for me who had a hard time
understanding all this here's a chart
that helped Mia basically it's necessary
for an anti cheat to boot up and take a
virtual snapshot of your computer before
it boots into its user mode and what the
user mode is is that's the version of
your computer that me and you use with
all your programs you know your web
browser your games all that stuff this
way the program can see if anything's
changed from that original snapshot the
one that it takes as soon as you boot
your computer and identify if you're
cheating and this is what separates it
from a program that would start as soon
as you boot up
valid because there'd be no way for it
to tell if a chief had launched during
your startup before you jumped into your
user I know it's a little convoluted but
the best way I can describe it is that
if cheaters are designing cheats to go
deeper into your computer then the anti
cheat has to be just as intrusive and to
better understand the technical side of
this I spoke to a guy named Carl Shu he
goes searching for exploits in games as
a hobby and post them to his website so
that game developers can go in and stop
the cheats in their tracks
the primary goal of an institute is to
be able to detect any behavior on the
computer that isn't like normal whatever
like what you would classify as
malicious behavior because there are
something that never should happen on a
computer like patching the Windows
kernel should never absolutely never
happen that's why it's the exactly the
same thing that answer eyes look for and
to be able to detect manipulations like
that you kind of need to be able to
monitor the entire system which is what
most of the normal gamers would classify
as intrusive because you need high
privileges read like full system control
over the machine Carl actually wrote an
article trying to disseminate some of
this exact same misinformation about
Vanguard just a few days maybe the most
prominent thing that he said to me that
stood out from this whole conversation
is that software like this isn't new at
all even though it's right now that
we're talking about it also according to
him it doesn't offer much more invasion
than when you just boot up a game
regularly face it for example in
counter-strike has been using intrusive
anti cheat software for years he even
told me that peripherals like your mouse
and keyboard use kernel drivers just
like van Gogh there's really not that
much stopping your everyday tech company
who made your keyboard from accessing
your information even there's a reason
why that badly no malware is ever ready
to go kernel because you simply do not
need it like if you need to spy on
someone it'd be much easier to just do
it from user mode it's much easy to hide
as well if you are scared of Riot Games
like muddy than your computer you
shouldn't play the game at all so what
we've really got here is a new game from
riot with a piece of software that a lot
of people were concerned about early on
but after doing a little bit of digging
I think it's pretty safe to say that
it's actually not as
common as people think and honestly it's
starting to become the standard after
speaking with two experts I think there
is one very simple takeaway from all of
this if you really want a cheater free
experience you're going to have to be
okay with intrusive images those are
just the facts and Riot Games actually
mirrored this sentiment in the recent
patch notes where they acknowledge that
there was some backlash against the anti
cheat but maintained that this was the
best way to keep their game clean from
cheaters look by no means am i a genius
when it comes to computers like many of
you I've built one which is more or less
Lego and I use one for work so when I
hear words like intrusive I get a little
spooked too I mean who wouldn't I don't
want my privacy to be impacted but after
talking to gamer doc and Carl I think
it's pretty clear that riot is more or
less following an industry stand look at
the end of the day you're gonna have to
decide whether you're comfortable about
this or not
but for what I can tell at least right
now there doesn't seem to be anything
malicious going on this is the this is
this is the thing right it's like those
games were like designed to be able to
cheat in so like like for example like
um I mean for me it was probably like
Tony Hawk like I remember like unlocking
like new skateboards and like I think
you could like play Tony Hawk it's like
a as like a Reaper or something we had
this job growing up when we were kids
that that uh we dress like default
skaters cuz like they would always be
like they would always be like the
default skater from from Tony Hawk or
from skate where like my friends would
always say that we all dress like
default skaters who's funny